cool so thank you for that lovely
introduction I'm going to be talking
about improving pi spark performance
today so hopefully you're interested in
pi spark if not that's totally cool too
you can zone out trying my talk it's all
good and so this is sort of spark is
written in the JVM and so this is
focused on spark performance beyond the
JVM I've done a bunch of things with
spark and other stuff I'm from Canada
but right now I'm in San Francisco i'm
at IBM spark technology center and we
are hiring if there's anyone else who is
crazy enough to come from San Francisco
to Amsterdam for pi data and you want a
job come talk to me but I'm assuming
most of you are not interested in moving
to San Francisco so I'll save you are
normal recruiting spiel the slides from
today's talk are on my slide share so if
you're interested in seeing the slides
or some of the slides from my previous
talks maybe if you're not super familiar
with a pice park already i also have a
previous introduction video at a
previous PI data in Seattle which i
think is pretty good but I'm pretty
biased so you know whatever so I'm gonna
sort of cover a bunch of different
topics it's kind of a grab bag I'm gonna
start with who I hope you all are and if
I get a lot of blank faces will take
some more time on some of the different
slides we'll do a sort of brief overview
of sparked components we're only going
to focus on on the ones that really
impact performance today and we're also
going to look at sort of the general
architecture of Pi spark because it's
kind of weird and this this really weird
architecture actually has some really
big impacts on on sort of what things
are slow and then we're going to talk
about sports sequel which is a new
amazing wonderful thing which saves us
from from all our our trouble except
when it crashes and then I'm going to
tell you how to mix JVM in Python code
for awesomeness
and it's more for minimizing sadness
rather than awesomeness you still get to
write some of your Python code but from
time to time if you're if you're working
in spark you you do get stuck having to
ride some JVM code if you really want to
get good performance and then at the end
though I'll wrap up with some cute
pictures of cats and some key value data
sort of just general spark things they
apply to pi spark as well but they apply
to scholars park just as easily so I'm
hoping you're all nice people if you're
not I don't want to find out everyone
here knows Python right yeah okay I've
got a few maybes so all the examples are
in Python I'm hoping you don't mind
pictures of cats if you do you're gonna
have to ignore the the top right-hand
part of my slides so this is my
assumption that people know some Apache
spark is this true can you raise your
hands if you know some Apache spark okay
that's pretty good and for those of you
that know no Apache spark you're still
awesome but I want to know how many of
them there are okay cool that's that's
actually a pretty good mix so for those
of you that don't know any apache spark
there are going to be some acronyms that
don't make a lot of sense and you can
ask me a question if it's just like
completely out there but after this talk
you might find it beneficial to watch
one of my previous sort of more
introductory talks and then it'll sort
of put a lot of these things in
perspective I think you can still get
some good value from it because I cover
some interesting architecture stuff and
I'm assuming everyone's here because you
like performance you know if you're
working with kilobytes of data it's cool
you can probably just go and grab
another coffee it's not going to be a
big deal so let's that's my intro
there's another picture of a cat because
I love cats but so what is spark for for
those of you that have no idea what
spark is it's a really awesome
general-purpose distributed system a lot
of people come to spark just because
they're looking for something faster
than MapReduce which is a really low bar
but it's
really low bar spark jumps over for a
lot of things it can be like a hundred
times faster is the standard benchmark
which is probably about as true as your
average vendor benchmark but it is
actually much faster in a lot of
production jobs as well but I think one
of the really nice things about smart
compared to like traditional MapReduce
type systems is the API is so much more
expressive and it's really wonderful and
you're not stuck trying to like cram all
of your things together into mapper and
reduce tasks and doing a bunch of really
weird things to get reasonable
performance we have to do some weird
things which we'll talk about today but
not nearly as many so there's all of
these wonderful components and today
we're going to be focusing on the Python
api's and sequel and data frames for
those of you that know pandas don't get
your hopes up spark data frames are not
pandas data frames I'm sorry but they're
really cool and they do give us sort of
a data frame like view into our data and
on these different pieces of spark they
all ship together which is really
convenient as users so if we want to do
some machine learning after we've done
some sort of sequel transformations it's
really easy to make these systems work
together we don't have to save it out to
another system and launched yet another
distributed computing system it all
works together and also because these
are all developed together a lot of
sparks performance comes from sort of
improvements that were made in in
different components so for example
streaming had to really really lower the
task creation overhead so that it could
it could run really quickly for for its
micro batches but this benefited sequel
as well because you have this much lower
task overhead that was necessary for
streaming to be successful but it also
benefits sequel especially for small
queries so let's let's look at how pie
spark is made it's not nearly as fun as
this playground that's actually pretty
sad so spark is in Scala how do it was
pais part actually work it uses pie for
Jade it has anyone here used pie for
Jay my condolences um unless the PI
forge a maintainer soup man which case I
love you um uses Piper J pickling in a
fair amount of magic and this can
actually be really slow the rd DS which
are the sparks way of representing
distributed data are r dds of pickled
objects which is kind of painful right
you you're having to serialize your
stuff shove it into the JVM and then
shuffle around and spark sequel is
pretty cool because it's sort of avoid
some of this problem we don't have to
shuffle around pickled objects we can we
can actually do our operations on JVM
objects and this can be less less
painful but this is sort of what you
know the world's worst architecture
diagram for 4 PI spark looks like so on
our driver program we have our Python
interpreter and it's calling the JVM
over PI for j and on our workers we're
using unix pipes to send data from the
JVM to our worker python processes which
is kind of you know slow it's it's not
as slow as you know writing it out to
disk and reading it back in but it's
it's not exactly fast either compared to
just keeping the data inside of the JVM
and yeah so the double serialization
cost is really the expensive part about
this and the biggest takeaway for for
working with PI spark is we want to try
and avoid this double serialization cost
surprisingly for distributed systems
like spark a lot of our time is spent
just serializing our data are actual
like computations themselves are
frequently not the the big blocking part
a lot of it is just serializing stuff
and shuffling things around not exactly
directly related performance wise but
for those of you who have used pi spark
you might have noticed that the error
messages make no sense it's not just you
the error messages make no sense I'm
sorry we should fix it someday
okay so that was the sadness let's look
at how we can make this happy like this
cat so this wouldn't be a big data talk
if I didn't have word count and I like
keeping my big data license so I'm going
to give you a word count so for those of
you who aren't super familiar with spark
the first bit is sort of loading our
data in and this is Leslie evaluated and
then spark is able to sort of chain the
additional operations together and do
some sort of intelligence stuff for us
and once we perform this action spark
actually you know evaluates all of the
transformations that we've done and has
to do its its then one one cool thing to
note is what we do have this double
serialization cost we don't pay it on
like a per operation basis we pay it
whenever we get to the point where spark
can't pipeline things together right so
this flat map and map they're going to
get pipeline together so we don't have
to worry about like adding more maps and
try and do the crazy things that we were
doing in the hadoop world for for good
performance right it'sit's we do our map
and then we do this produced by key and
then okay yeah we get hit again because
we're having to bring our data into the
JVM shuffle it around and write it back
out to the workers but in theory data
frames are going to fix this for us
right so that's wonderful we can we can
keep our data inside the JVM but we can
still write Python code and so that's
like that's a pretty good win-win it
takes our Python code in it it gets
converted into a query plan and this is
pretty good you know um they're not
pandas or our data frames it helps if
you lower your expectations down to
sequel and then occasionally you get
surprised when there's slightly more
there but the really nice thing is if if
we have some really like massive data
problem right frequently we're only
interested in subsets of this data for
actual analysis so if we can do our
initial filtering or our initial sorting
using data frames and then do the
subsequent work with our dd's we're able
to get like much better performance than
just doing the work
in our duties because the the initial
big expensive part is happening all
inside of the JVM so essentially what
happens is our are really nice lambda
expressions get replaced with these
these sequel expressions and that's okay
right um but you know you probably don't
want to do this unless we actually get
good performance from it so what does
what does data frame performance look
like so compared to group by key amazing
but group by key in spark is is pretty
much the devil so that's not all that
impressive but you know we would
probably write something that was doing
a group by key with a reduced by key
anyways and we can see that data frames
still outperform a native reduced by key
and this is computing the average on
some columns I don't remember how many
it might have been like five or six but
this is just just a really simple
computation and you can see that it
still outperforms even inside of Scala
and inside of scala data frames aren't
saving us from this double serialization
overhead they're just you know saving us
from writing you know terrible Scala
code so this this improvement is is even
bigger for for Python so we should try
and rewrite word count so that it's
extra fast and that are 100 x benchmark
that we show to people can be a 200 x
benchmark but we don't have a way to to
split our words there's no sequel thing
implemented to do that really easily for
us so we could do we could do a few
different things data frames can go back
to our dd's really easily so we could do
that we could we could make our data
frame take it into an RDD and then
switch it back to a data frame that's
about as fun as it sounds which is not
very we could write a UDF or if we were
in spark 2.0 which doesn't yet exist but
will very soon at some point we could we
could use data sets which are really
awesome and they let us sort of write
these functional style transformation
while keeping our data in a data set so
we don't have to convert to an RDD and
back so you know um data frame to our DD
and back again we can just write a
standard map transformation converting
it back we could have spark
automatically and for the schema for us
but that's going to be kind of expensive
so instead we probably we know what our
schema is so we can just specify the
schema so word count with data frames I
didn't specify the schema gear because
it doesn't fit super well onto a single
slide but would count with data frames
looks pretty similar we have our flat
map and our flat map is still going to
have this double serialization cost but
when we're doing our actual shuffle down
here we're doing our shuffle on JVM
objects and we're not doing it even on
like just brought JVM objects we're
doing it on these these really cool
objects that in their serialized form
are actually comparable so it's it's
super happy sparked sequels data formats
are really awesome and so this this
computes our word count using spread
sequel but we we still do pay some of
the double serialization costs and and
we want to get out of that right so what
can we do we could make a UDF turns out
if we make a UDF we still pay the double
serialization cost but we can feel nicer
about it so that doesn't really do a lot
for us but we could we could actually
make a java UDF instead this is a little
sad right because I'm essentially
telling you to get good performance for
pi spark we need to do some stuff in the
JVM well it's not that bad you write
some Scala code I it's if you do it for
the parts which are really expensive and
you keep your Python code for the parts
which are really awesome in Python I
think it's worth it especially when you
consider the fact that you can really
easily use udfs from things like hive or
existing libraries there's a
ton of like sparks gala libraries and if
we're willing to play sort of fast and
loose with accessing internal members we
can get really good performance so let's
go ahead and start playing fast and
loose with asks to sing some internal
methods so we'll start that by creating
evil sequel tools and evil sequel tools
will let us sort of get at the
underlying components of a spark column
and this is useful if we want to pass a
column in rather than creating a UDF and
writing some sequel statements so
essentially we could we could call
kurtosis on a column name rather than
going dots equals select kurtosis i mean
they're both fine but one of them i get
to have something that starts with the
word evil so I like evil but now we need
to we need to actually you know be able
to call these functions that we wrote in
Scala for us most of the things have
underscored J object type and that gives
you the the Java backing object so if we
want to pass in an RDD to ask allah
function maybe someone has a really
awesome Scala spark library will just
pass it in our DD underscore JR DD and I
mean DF is dot underscore jdf and so on
the catch is right these things are all
internal methods so if we go ahead and
use these it's probably going to explode
at some point in the future but for at
least the next several months you'll get
much nicer performance and someone else
will be stuck maintaining your code once
you quit and get a better job or at
least that's the American Way the one
catches the PI forge a bridge only
exists on the driver so we can't with
the notable exception of sparks dreaming
but so we need to call our methods on
the driver rather than trying to call
them on the worker and if we try and
call them on the worker it'll just
explode at runtime with an error message
that makes no sense but so this is this
is how we start and actually go ahead
and call random methods on the on the
JVM so our sport context has this
underscore JVM
and then we can just go and type the the
full path to our object so in this case
it's from a project that I worked on
called sparkling pandas which is a
project for from making pandas like data
frame interfaces in spark and so this we
have a function called register UDF and
we just go ahead and we go dot
underscore JVM com sparkling pandas
functions register UDF and and I pass in
my my sequel contacts so that it can do
its work and we can call this will on a
column for the kurtosis function we can
call this on on really almost any object
that we're working with in spark so
that's cool but maybe maybe I haven't
convinced you I'm seeing a lot of people
that don't look like they want to go
home and write JVM code and retrospect
Python conference should have been
obvious not a not going to be a really
easy sell so I mean let's say we just
want to work with data frames and we
don't want to go ahead and access crazy
internal things what sort of things do
we need to do so we can get really good
performance from data frames there's a
bunch of things essentially that we just
don't want to do and then we're going to
get good performance one thing is we
don't want really really huge schemas on
our data frames because for some reason
there see realized is JSON data and
passed as a driver programming back
which is okay for for medium-sized data
frames but if you start having a column
for every individual user that's gonna
not go so well so don't do that um the
other one is there's this really awesome
function on data frames called two
pandas and it lets us take a spark data
frame and get back a pandas dataframe
the thing is to pandas is essentially
collect what it does is it takes our
wonderful distributed data frame and it
brings it back to our local node which
promptly falls over because we tried to
bring back 80 gigs of data to a gig
laptop so don't call two pandas unless
you're really really sure you've
actually filter to dance to some small
data another one is it's really easy to
accidentally do the cross product of
your data in spark
and the cross product of a big data and
a big data is an outofmemory exception
so when you're writing your joins it's
really important to actually think about
what you're joining on and if you're
joining on something which maybe has an
lvalue maybe eighty percent of you know
your keys are no it's actually going to
do the cross product for all of the
things which are now and then it's going
to explode and fall over so you should
filter out those null values before you
do your join another thing is if you're
like a really experienced rtd programmer
in spark data frames have like some
little weird quarks for them they're not
quite as lazy as our dd's right so as
we're doing our transformations spark
would normally not give us any sort of
error messages as to what's going on but
with data frames and we're loading our
data it sort of infers some schema
information so if we try and load some
data that doesn't exist it's going to
yell at us or if we try and select a
column that doesn't exist it's going to
yell at us and I mean those are all
probably good things to find out about
sooner rather than later but you know
it's it's something to keep in mind so
why is grouped by key so slow anyways
right back back on the first slide when
I was trying to convince you to use data
frames I said you know this outperforms
group by key but that's not actually you
know all that impressive how many people
think group by key should not be
terrible okay that's a good number of
people I tried to convince people of
this once um in inside of the spark that
we should actually wrap the group by key
API in something the one over like a
lead balloon but I'm optimistic that
some some year I'm going to get people
to change their minds most likely
actually what's going to happen is data
frames and data sets will take over and
this won't matter but for now group by
key is pretty much the devil it's really
easy to make group by Kieff all over and
it's important to sort of just remember
that while group bike he performs really
badly a lot of the problems we can get
with it we can get with other operations
so you know what are these problems
essentially once we start working with
key value data and we start trying to do
operations
we should actually think about what the
distribution of our keys looks like it's
probably sort of natural to a lot of the
data scientists in the room but maybe
for some of the data engineers you're
not used to thinking about like what the
distribution of your data looks like or
you don't have a very intuitive
understanding of of you know how many
orders happen on Tuesdays and you try
and do a group by key by day of week we
should think about what type of
aggregations we want to do and we all
seem to think if we need our data in a
particular order could this cause a
problem and it turns out it can actually
cause a problem all of these things can
cause problems so how do they cause
problems sookie sookie everyone had data
with key skill if you've work with real
data sales by postal code records by
city we can have unbalanced partitions
and then that's okay our spark job will
look like it's going along it'll chug
along and we'll have some stragglers but
it will succeed eventually but we can
also end up with partitions that are
just too big for spark to process and we
can end up with records which are too
big right so group by key is pretty evil
and what that group like he actually
does is group all of the records with
the same key into a single record even
if we immediately do a reduction on it
afterwards so even if we do a group by
key followed by a sum or really anything
spark isn't able to introspect the
second lambda expression we're providing
it all it knows is that we asked it to
do this group by key and this is this is
sort of one of the limitations of the
rtd API and this is this is one of the
benefits of using the data frame API is
spark is able to better understand what
we're asking it to do and it's able to
see that while we've asked it to group
this data together we then did a
reduction on it and it can actually
understand that it can it can pipeline
this reduction and start doing really
awesome things for us so right and less
foreign sequel than happy pandas so this
is what the explosion looks like 94 110
is a zip code in the mission
so this could be handlebar mustaches
which are very popular in the mission I
notice a complete lack of handlebar
mustaches here which is a little bit
depressing I'm going to be honest so you
know word count with group by key we
could write it this way and if we didn't
know that group by key was the devil
this looks like a pretty reasonable way
to write this code right and the normal
version is pretty simple right all we do
is we replace our rooms are grouped by
key with a reduced by key and the
reduced by key tells spark like hey
what's up actually I do want this
information on a perky basis but this is
the aggregation that I'm going to be
performing I'm going to be like summing
these two values together and I mean
this is a pretty simple aggregation but
we can express a lot of other
aggregations so we can compare these two
like maybe you don't believe me maybe
you think group i key is actually
implemented really amazingly so we could
we could run this code oh crap i forgot
to replace this one with python sorry a
little bit of scholar code but we could
run these two and and we can see you
know i'm working on kilobytes of data
because i wanted the job to actually
finish but you know with group by key we
we have a shuffled right of 424
kilobytes a shuffled read of 48
kilobytes with reduced by key are
shuffled right is actually all the way
down to 376 and are shuffled read is
11.6 so why did we get these these
smaller numbers so we replaced group by
key with reduced by key and one of the
really awesome things about spark is I
mean unless we tell it otherwise it's
these are reduced by key or an aggregate
by key and it says hey what's up I'm
going to reduce my data before I even
start shuffling it so essentially we get
a free map side combined what happens is
each worker goes and finds any duplicate
keys applies the reductions it can
locally and then it does a shuffle now
if we know for example that our data
there's there's no point in doing that
right like we're doing a group by key or
we know each partition has unique values
we can tell spark know whats up its cool
i know better don't don't actually apply
this map size reduction
it's cool so so the reason why we saw
these smaller shuffled writes and reads
is that we were like essentially
reducing our data beforehand so not only
did our job have the chance to succeed
it also took less network bandwidth and
took less time so um one thing that I
sort of skimmed over was that we read in
Python star dot pie and this is instead
of the standard my favorite one is
reading in the readme file which is also
kilobytes of data and finishes very
quickly but the readme file doesn't have
enough duplicated words to actually show
a difference right and this is the case
where group by key while it's the devil
if you occasionally want to worship the
devil that's cool with me but no your
data distribution first right if you
have mostly unique keys and the ones
that are duplicated aren't duplicated
all that often group by key is ok but
you should probably still be a good
person and use aggregate by key but if
you're going to go ahead and use group
by key I mean I'm not going to be around
22 tisk tisk at you and and spark isn't
going to fall over and lose all your
data so it's ok but you know just
remember what your data distribution
looks like so that's cool what about if
we just want to sort our data right I'm
interested in seeing like sort of all of
the people that are in the same zip code
I want to know where the handlebar like
all sorry I want to see all the people
in the same zip code who have handled
our mustaches so I'm going to sort my
data I'm not going to group it together
by key because I got told not to do that
so I know that's a bad thing but it
could still explode if we if we try to
do our shuffle right our shuttle
explosion looks like this right well we
don't have this massive key we still get
a partition which has too much data in
it and I mean too much data is sort of a
relative term but we'll pretend it it
gave us an out of memory exception right
handlebar mustaches probably wouldn't do
this but if I try to sort like sales by
zip code there's a really good chance
that I'm going to just actually like
makes Park fall over
but this is like a really legitimate
question to ask where I like I have I
have some information I want to sort by
it what do I do um so there's a few
different things oh okay the really lazy
answer is we just depend some jump to
the end of our key and that works what
will happen is spark is smart enough
that it actually samples our data and
uses us to determine what the
partitioner should look like so we just
need to give it a way to split this data
and it'll do it for us the downside of
doing this is if we do a joint
afterwards it's their joint is not going
to have a really good time but you know
we can just add some junk to the end of
our key or we could even add some of the
value to our key and you know our
shuffle would be fine so switching
topics pretty much completely from key
value data to reductions spark
reductions are actually kind of
frustratingly naively implemented by
default reduces the values per worker
and then sends all of those values to
the driver does anyone see a problem
with that you know okay well that's fine
and if you have like five workers that's
probably ok but if you have like 500
workers and you're getting these really
big values you might want to actually
try and apply your your reduction in
sort of a stage method so you know we we
reduce the values / partition and then
we combined adjacent partitions together
and then we finally send those results
back to the driver this isn't like
really something that you're probably
going to need to do very often so don't
just go out and replace every instance
of reduced with tree reduce but if
you're doing something like computing
maybe the residuals from a machine
learning model on a lot of nodes this
might be something that would make sense
to to do and you can sort of specify how
deep you want this tree to go and you
can play with that parameter so I did
say I would talk about our DD reuse and
and really the sad part is that unlike
this cat our DD reuses not
magic so in spark spark is amazing lazy
evaluation is like my best friend but
sometimes I want to use the same data
twice right how many of us you know
reading data and then we want to use it
more than once we want to perform like
two actions on it okay good people
haven't fallen asleep entirely that's
great so so quite a few people right and
there's a few different things we can do
we have to know which ones we want to
keep around and we have to tell spark to
keep these ones around for us so we can
cash it caching is great when our data
fits in memory but probably the reason
why you're using spark is your data is
really big and it might not fit in
memory even across your entire cluster
and then you know maybe you need to
catch multiple things right maybe you've
got users table and you've got like all
of your sales tables and then the
marketing people show up and they've got
another table they want to cache and you
know eventually you start to find things
getting evicted that's okay like sparked
handles these evictions gracefully it'll
just recompute the bits of data as
they're needed but it can be useful to
actually just have spark right it out to
disk as well and if our computations are
really expensive and our clusters are
noisy how many people have clusters
where you lose nodes occasionally during
your jobs okay a good number of people
so so for those of you who who work on
noisy clusters maybe the AWS spot
instances it can be useful to cash to
multiple machines so that if like some
of our mission use get killed you know
we don't have to recompute that part of
the data this is especially true for
things with shuffles or what's called
wide dependencies so if our in spark if
we use a map transformation creates a
narrow dependency and this is our our
partition output depends on a set number
of no one partitions inputs so when we
need to recompute it we know which
pieces we need to go upstream and
recompute but if we have like a shuffle
I might depend on recomputing all of the
previous data even if I only lost one
partition downstream right and so that
can be really expensive especially if
you had like a
lot of work going in to computing the
data before that shuffle and if you're
on a really noisy cluster you can try
checkpointing checkpointing essentially
gives you the MapReduce hammer of
writing everything out to disk and it
gets rid of using sparks recompute
method and this normally isn't a good
idea but if you're on a really noisy
cluster and your data is really
expensive to recompute checkpointing is
is actually a really good technique
checkpointing is normally used for when
we've applied so many transformations to
an RDD that it becomes difficult for
spark to keep track of them but it can
also be used for when our cluster is
just really really unreliable like if we
bid 20 cents on our AWS spot instances
it's it's probably a good idea to do
checkpointing so probably a good reason
why you want to use PI spark is you've
got some libraries that you want to use
and this isn't this isn't really
performance but you know if you how many
people are using Python with with
libraries that don't ship in just the
standard Python right that's everyone
okay how many of you have the all those
libraries installed on every single node
in your cluster okay too um so your Co
drums and that's great but for the rest
of you you probably occasionally have
the sadness when you you have some
distributed code it depends on some
library and then it fails and you're
like oh crap I forgot to install it on
this machine that's pretty cool right
okay sorry yeah um so there's a few
different things we can do if our if our
you know generic python library comes in
a zip or egg file we can distribute it
we can use dash dash zip files or just
the add PI file function on the spark
context to distribute our library and so
that's really awesome except it doesn't
work for many of the library's that we
care about which is a little sad another
one is if you someone gave you the root
key is to your cluster you can use pssh
and install your libraries on all the
nodes and it's a little sketchy and kind
of sad but it works and the other one is
the CD h plus continuum plus anaconda
equals approximate sanity so there's
there's some really cool stuff from the
clutter or people and they make it
really easy use anaconda with cdh and
you can install your packages this this
replace previous bullet point which said
you know sadness and crying so
approximate sanity is a great
improvement yeah so this wouldn't be a
talk if I didn't try and pitch you on a
book that you should clearly by six
copies of one for home one for work and
several just to you know throw in the
dustbin but I'm working on another book
called high performance park I think
it's pretty cool but I'm obviously
incredibly biased the examples are
really scowl eccentric but if you care
about spark performance I think it's
still really interesting even with the
Scala centered examples and there is a
section that's going to be dedicated to
working beyond the JVM and sort of the
things that you need to do to survive
and will eventually port the Python the
examples to Python in my copious spare
time which I'm sure will happen this
year probably don't hold me to it but if
you feel like giving me your email
address to spam high-performance spark
calm and I will spend you mercilessly as
soon as you can give a Riley money for
the book and there's also a Twitter
account which i forgot about until I saw
this slide so you could also follow that
account on Twitter and actually will
probably be having an early release of
the first four chapters later on this
month although admittedly we don't get
into any of the Python specific stuff
yet but a lot of the sort of the general
techniques as well as sort of some
examples of how to work with data frames
are in there so i think it's school I've
got a bunch of spark videos and there's
a whole bunch of spark videos from
people that aren't me I think Pacos in
terms of spark video a
is amazing if you're not just interested
in learning specifically pi spark I
really encourage you to check out Paco's
videos yeah these these links are in the
SlideShare if you want to take a look at
it or you can just search for Paco's
introduction to apache spark he also if
you have a corporate credit card you can
buy his introduce park video but it's
also for free on youtube if you don't
have a corporate credit card the but the
you know fancy o'reilly one looks nicer
and you should you should support paco
with you if you have the money i'm also
going to do office hours so this was
sort of a random grab bag of topics of
things that i hope people might find
useful there's a good chance that what I
was talking about wasn't particularly
useful to the stuff you're working on
but you can come hang out with me at the
booking.com offices wherever they are I
need to find that out tomorrow at 6pm
and you should sign up on the meetup so
they security people have their list and
you can ask me any spark questions and I
will give you an answer or not depending
on if I know it or can figure it out you
should also follow me on Twitter or
LinkedIn I mostly have pictures of cats
and complaints about American health
care on Twitter but I do occasionally
talk about spark and LinkedIn is very
much business numbers so that's that's
my kay thanks bye there's a cat this is
by
so being a cat person as well I have to
compliment you on the final slide
because it does add sort of an extra
nice little painted all talk thanks for
the talk it's always good to have like
an in-depth talk on technologies that
everyone here is using are there any
questions for Holden as Holden's
mentioned there's always the office
hours but I see there's someone in the
two people and got you
I actually have a couple so I come I
come by afterwards but let me ask at
least one about the group by key yeah
sometimes you don't want to aggregate if
you want to group the data but you don't
want to aggravate it so what would you
suggest it's a group lucky if you want
to group your data but you don't have a
subsequent reduction or aggregation to
perform doing a shuffle possibly doing a
shuttle while adding some jump to it and
then you can use you can use map
partitions to process it on a per
partition basis essentially manually do
do your logical processing that way it's
really nasty I have an example of doing
it for high-performance park soon Scala
but the same logic applies it's it's a
little ugly though and I'm sorry
so there's something that's called Jason
yeah it's not in a wonderful state
especially when combined with Python 3
but knowing things about Scala and spark
do you think it could be a viable
approach to reevaluate that option sure
styling Python to JPM and then accessing
natively all these objects instead of
doing this double civilization that's
yeah um if jython worked well with
libraries that people cared about I
think that would change the conversation
completely but I think realistically
right now using Jai thon just really
wouldn't be that beneficial because most
of the libraries that people are really
you know frankly using Python for aren't
aren't there I i looked at doing some
stuff with it and when i was working on
sparkling pandas not not inside the
spark itself and it just wasn't there
but I mean if that changes you know the
spark people are definitely open to
changing things especially in the
language api is there's a fair amount of
flexibility there so i think we might
have time for one more final question if
there is one this is
thank you for the talk I wrote it I
wrote a note about as park 2.2 and you
mentioned the we won't expect data frame
anymore in that version I've
misunderstood that okay the the question
was sparked todaro don't expect data
frames anymore I thought something like
that I don't know could you please
elaborate on don't worry so data frames
will continue to exist in spark 20 data
sets are coming as well though and they
make it even easier to intermix
functional and relational style
programming so essentially if we if we
look all the way back here right after I
did my my flat map I had to manually
convert it back to these row objects and
that's kind of janky and essentially
with data sets we're not going to have
to do this really Jenky stuff it's just
going to work for us and that's going to
be lovely and wonderful but you know we
can the data frame API will still be
there the data set API is is just sort
of building on the success of data
frames cool thank you so much for having
me and putting up with my occasional
Scala code and I am very sorry about the
Scala code I think the Scala code is
just fine please give them another round
house for Holden and boo